what i want to do in this video is
attempt to find the diameter of this
circle right over here and i encourage
you to pause the video and try this out
on your own
well let's think about what's going on
right over here a b is definitely the a
diameter of the circle it's a straight
line it's going through the center of
the circle o is the center of the circle
right over here
and so what do we know
well we could look at this angle right
over here angle c
and think about it is an inscribed angle
and think about the arc that it
intercepts
it intercepts this arc
right over here
this arc is exactly half of the circle
this arc right over here is exactly half
of the circle angle c is inscribed if
you take these two sides or the two
sides of the angle it intercepts at a
and b and so it intercepts an arc this
green arc right over here so the central
angle right over here is 180 degrees and
the inscribed angle is going to be half
of that it's going to be 90 degrees
or another way of thinking about it it's
going to be a right angle
and what that does for us is it tells us
that triangle a c b
triangle a
c
b
is a right triangle
this is a right triangle and the
diameter is its hypotenuse so we can
just apply the pythagorean theorem here
15 squared
15 squared plus 8 squared
plus 8 squared let me do this in magenta
plus 8 squared is going to be the length
of side a b squared so let me just call
this let me just call this side right
over here let me just call that x
that's going to be equal to
x squared so 15 squared that's 225
8 squared is 64
plus 64 is equal to x squared
i would do that in green
is equal
to x squared 225 plus 64
is 289
is equal to x squared and then 289
is 17 squared and you could try out a
few numbers if you're unsure about that
so x
is equal to
17. so the diameter or the diameter of
the circle right over here is 17.